a mysterious outbreak among children
here in the u.s the cdc is saying that a
sixth child has died from severe
hepatitis and 180 kids in the us have
been infected that's since october most
recovered but 15 had needed organ
transplants scientists are baffled and
wonder if it could be linked to the
coronavirus pandemic senior medical
correspondent dr tara nerula spoke to
one family that suddenly found
themselves in a life or death situation
with their little girl
two-year-old baylin schwab may look
healthy now but just a few weeks ago the
south dakota toddler's health took a
sudden turn her eyes looked a little bit
yellow we took her into the doctor and
all of her liver enzyme labs were
extremely elevated doctors told baylen's
mom her liver was inflamed she was flown
to mhealth fairview masonic children's
hospital in minneapolis at that point
did they have any idea what might be
going on for the first like three days
we really had no clue what was happening
and then all of a sudden the next day
hit and kind of everything just went
chaos her lab skyrocketed neurologically
she wasn't really a hundred percent
there it was very hard and you see your
kid deteriorating like right in front of
your eyes like overnight can i pick you
up bailin had severe hepatitis and her
liver was failing dr sreenath chinokotla
is her doctor and has already performed
a transplant this year on an even
younger child we would do maybe one
transplant for liver failure a year or
maybe every other year
but this year we have already done two
transplants for acute liver failure so
that's certainly a concern for us baylon
went to the top of the transplant list
and within days a donor was found
after the eight-hour transplant surgery
doctors found that ninety percent of her
removed liver was damaged tissue i'm
actually thrilled with the entire
progress palin is getting stronger every
day and that strength runs in the family
in december the schwabs had to pull
together when their youngest 11-month
old laramie died from sudden infant
death syndrome
everyone is anxious to have bailin back
home what does your older daughter
understand about what has happened to
her sister she was a little bit
concerned because last time she had
sister that went to the hospital she
didn't come home so she's been really
struggling with understanding what's
going on how will you explain this to
baylen when she's old enough to
understand i think she's defied all odds
as far as
recovery and how fast she's bouncing
back she honestly is an inspiration for
me
bailin is still in the hospital she's
done remarkably well so far in her
recovery but will have to take
anti-rejection medications for the rest
of her life and be closely monitored for
transplant rejection and the risks
associated with the medications boy glad
to hear she's doing well it's a lot of
suffering for one family
and a lot of parents can be worried
seeing that wondering if it could happen
in their family so what are the symptoms
they should be looking for right so
let's first point out that this is
extremely rare and in the call that the
cdc gave on friday they said that this
is not yet considered a spike or an
outbreak but actually something notable
is sort of how they put it most of the
patients or the cases have recovered
right so we want to kind of caveat all
of this with that that being said
parents should be aware that the median
age is around two so this is really
affecting young preschoolers it's been
seen in 36 states and the symptoms would
be nausea vomiting abdominal pain fever
jaundice so when the eyes or the skin
look yellow dark urine or light-colored
stool joint pain and fatigue and if you
see any of that you definitely want to
alert your pediatrician it's hard to see
your children sick what what do you
think caused it well that case that's
really the big question and so the cdc
is going to have to kind of uncover this
medical mystery in many of the same ways
that they did if you remember with acute
flaccid myelitis a couple of years ago
so it's putting together the medical
records exposures lab data what's
happening around the world
at this point in time the leading
hypothesis is that there may be some
association with adenovirus 41. this is
a virus that typically causes a
gastrointestinal illness in children not
usually hepatitis but they're saying
it's possible that there are a couple of
things that could be happening number
one kids were not exposed to adenovirus
that much in the last couple years
because of the mitigation strategies so
that may have affected how they're
reacting to it now it may be that
adenovirus 41 in combination with
another infection so for example covet
if they had been exposed to covid that
may have primed their immune system in
such a way that they're having a hyper
immune reaction maybe this is some other
unusual strain or different strain of
adenovirus so a lot of leading
hypotheses that they're investigating
right now and it's going to take a
little time yeah tara thank you so much
we appreciate it good to see you again